[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the chief
leader writer at the observer sonia
soder and soon i am promised uh henry
hill deputy editor of conservative home
but let's bring you uh straight away
those front pages
starting with the eye which leads with
the continuing flow of migrants across
the channel despite britain
apparently aiming to fly illegal
migrants to rwanda to try to discourage
the traffickers who get them here in the
first place
the telegraph reports on those last
minute efforts by the european court of
human rights to stop the deportations
that has been effective of course we
understand
which says the guardian has thrown the
entire plan into chaos
and after the news that the plane isn't
leaving the metro calls it a rwandan air
farce
the financial times meanwhile leads with
job losses in the cryptocurrency
industry as the value of currencies fall
while the sun claims an exclusive with
news that boxer tyson fury is planning a
200 million pound return to the ring
well the horror of horrors the star has
news of a shortage of flake bars to go
into our ice creams in the coming heat
wave
wallpapers due in we'll bring you those
when we see them uh reminder though that
by scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us so let's
bring in sonia as we await our other
guests uh sign you down to you for the
moment and of course the news uh tonight
uh that that plane the first plane this
hugely controversial flight to rwanda
has been grounded as the daily telegraph
puts it because of the intervention of
european judges
yes this is huge news to what we've seen
in recent days is a number of people on
this flight that could have taken up to
300 people to rwanda come down and down
and down as legal challenges were
successful in getting people off this
flight and that's because we got to
remember these are people seeking refuge
they fled countries like iraq syria
iran
we know some of the people seemed to be
on the plane had very serious mental
health problems doctors have found
evidence that they are likely to have
been subject to torture in regimes like
iraq so this is why these legal appeals
have been successful and tonight what
we've seen is the european uh court of
human rights um stepping in and saying
that the flights should not go ahead and
the reason for that is because this is
being subject to challenge in the uk's
courts
and um that judicial review is ongoing
so what the government's always argued
is well we can just deport people anyway
and if it's found that our actions were
unlawful we'll just bring them back but
what the european court has said tonight
is that actually there aren't um good
means whereby you know
you know it's a different jurisdiction
so how do we know that these people
would be able to get back that they
would be able to come back so that's why
it's instructed the government that it
needs to wait until this work the way
through the british courts and they get
a decision on whether this is actually a
lawful action or not well i just had the
first reaction from the home office
indeed from the home secretary pretty
patel herself it's long i'll read some
of it earlier this year i signed a world
leading migration partnership with
rwanda to see those arriving dangerously
illegally on or unnecessarily into the
uk relocated to build their lives there
this will help break the people a
smuggler's business model and prevent
loss of life while ensuring protection
for the genuinely vulnerable always the
government's argument of course and
access to the uk's asylum system must be
based on need not on the ability to pay
people smugglers the demands on the
current system the cost to the taxpayer
and the flagrant abuses are increasing
and the british public have rightly had
enough i've always said this policy will
not be easy to deliver and i'm
disappointed that legal challenge and
last-minute claims have meant today's
flight was unable to depart it is very
surprising that the european court of
human rights has intervened despite
repeated earlier success in our domestic
courts these repeated legal barriers are
similar to those we experience with
other removals flights and many of those
removed from this flight will be placed
on the next we will not be deterred from
doing the right thing and delivering our
plans to control our nation's borders
our legal team are reviewing every
decision made on this flight and
preparation for the next flight begins
now and certainly boris johnson uh
talked about the intervention of the
european court of human rights the daily
telegraph says it raises the prospect
that ministers could consider renouncing
membership of the european convention on
human rights to ensure that this scheme
can go ahead oh look henry hill has just
joined us welcome to you um from
conservative home and the whole point
about the european court of human rights
has nothing to do with brexit and the
european union is to do with our
membership of the council of europe and
our signatory as being a member of the
european convention on human rights so
will it be thrown out by the british
government in order for this policy to
go ahead boris johnson's suggesting that
may bring um
the government into difficulty uh with
uh more liberal conservatives um henry i
don't know how much of that you heard we
just had the the first reaction from the
home secretary uh your reaction to the
the news then that this plane for rwanda
will not take off
i think that it's uh
pretty vital and home office in general
have been short on win in recent recent
years as far as they're concerned and so
this looked as if until the very last
moment it was going to be something that
pretty patel could say that she had
managed to actually deliver as it is
there has been this last minute
intervention and now as you mentioned
the government is sort of lurching
towards maybe doing something about the
european convention on human rights now
it's slightly unfortunate the way this
has come about membership british
membership of the echr has greatly
exercised a section of conservative
opinion for quite a long time that sort
of conservative legal opinion which
feels that we should have an entirely
domestic regime of law and which will be
aggravated about the fact that something
can be upheld in every single british
court and then overruled but that's a
sort of point of principle and i think
it's going to it's going to if you like
as you mentioned color any principal
case for the repatriation of the legal
system entirely to britain if it is
launched on the basis of upholding this
particular very controversial policy the
random deportations do not have
universal support amongst the
conservative parliamentary party uh they
speak to a sort of conservatism which i
think some tory mps are worried is
alienating a section of the conservative
base in places like liberal democrat
facing seats and is presenting a
particular image of the conservative
party which is perhaps narrower than
they would like so i don't necessarily
rule out the government making noises
about leaving the echr but that is a big
change to our domestic legal order and
whatever the merits of it boris
johnson's government has not to date
proven particularly effective or indeed
enthusiastic about actually delivering
on big complicated pieces of policy
change and sonia quite aside from the
legal challenges of which the european
one is the latest as you know big
questions about the cost of this the
reported price on this plane which is
now not taking off was uh you know 500
half a million pounds rather the
government i know says that housing
refugees in deportation centers is
extremely expensive
but it's efficacy as well if you look at
the eye and the camera pictures we had
today you know hundreds more across the
channel and many of them from our
correspondence both in calais and in
dover reported that they had had nothing
about this rwanda policy so it's act as
a deterrent at the moment must also be
called into question
that's right well i think there's so
much wrong with british statement that
you just read out anna that it's hard to
know where to start you're absolutely
right the government makes a case for
this by saying it acts as a deterrent
actually the evidence that we do have
from you know these schemes are very
rare because they're thought to break
international law but israel
experimented with trying to forcibly
deport refugees um to the african
continent and what was found actually
was it dries up people smuggling
because people try and get back to the
countries that they were trying to get
to because they've got family there or
they speak the language so it doesn't
have a deterrent effect so those
arguments from the government
i think there's a couple of other things
to to to bring up about her statement as
well so she says uh you know i think
it's important to stress that
numbers arriving in the uk to claim
asylum people fleeing conflict war
terror etc they are actually lower than
they were at points in our past for
example just 20 years ago in the early
2000s we have far fewer claims for
asylum in this country than countries
like france and germany for example and
we grant refugee status to fewer people
per population head than countries
european countries like that as well
this idea that the system is in crisis
just isn't right it is absolutely true
that we don't want people to be
attempting this treacherous crossing um
you know of the english channel because
people are losing their lives but it is
just not right to say that numbers of
people claiming refuge are higher than
they've ever been in the uk for example
so i think it's really important to get
those facts
i'm sorry to interrupt you i've just
seen the time we're running very late
aren't we anyway that breaking news
we're keeping our own reaction to that
uh stay there both of you lots more
still to come in world newspapers back
in just a moment
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now the chief lead writer at the
observer sonia soda and henry hill
deputy editor of conservative home
welcome back to both of you henry let's
go to the ft shall we um their first
paragraph if i can read it boris
johnson's new cost of living czar is an
online entrepreneur who recently called
on the prime minister to quit and has
claimed that voting tori is a form of
self-harm uh discuss as they say
i think
i'm not i'm no i'm one of the prime
ministers critics but i think that to be
honest you do need to be prepared to do
stuff like this as prime minister not
least because when you hit this kind of
stage and borrows premiership if you
exclude everybody from government who's
called on you to resign you're talking
about a decent chunk of conservative mps
let alone people in the rest of the
country i think being part of being in
government is actually being able to to
be slightly bigger than that
partisanship to hire in people who don't
agree with you who even have said very
mean things about you if you think they
have something to contribute so i don't
know how the cost of living is going to
do i have vetted him um but i do think
that it is probably a good thing that
boris johnson still feels despite being
sort of under siege at the moment still
feels able to bring in outside advice
from critics
yes this is david buttress former chief
executive of just eat the online food
delivery group
who the government said would help
develop and promote initiatives that
help households and families with rising
costs we'll see how that goes um in the
meantime um a final minute sonia on
grenfell and with this great call still
five years on for
for justice both in terms of any
prosecutions and indeed actions that
people want to see for for other people
facing cladding
that's right so it was five years ago
that 72 people lost their lives in the
terrible fire at grenfell and
we had a memorial service today um which
was attended by uh prince william and uh
and his wife and uh theresa may and
sadiq khan but we've also very
importantly been hearing from relatives
who lost loved ones speaking out today
and what they're saying is they don't
want their loved ones um deaths to have
been in vain and we've got this long
public inquiry that's ongoing only half
of the recommendations so far have
actually been adopted into law by the
government and we're obviously still
waiting for individuals to be held
accountable the met police say that they
won't be able to run their investigation
until the inquiry is concluded but i
think there is a real sense speaking to
the families who are affected by
grenfell that we suffered this terrible
tragedy as a nation five years ago and
it just hasn't led to the level of
change that you would expect to see
sonia soda henry hill great to see both
of you thank you